what i wouldn't do to have your voice i
was saying that up front on top of the
show i heard that earlier you have
nothing to worry about you have a
delightful voice uh when my when i go
when i go through puberty it'll be
fantastic
until that time for the second time yeah
let's get the voice in the gym and
neutron thing out of the way because uh
there was a big disappointment in my
life and martin shorts who was featured
with me playing my sidekick
we
originally agreed to do this movie
because we had seen some
designs for jim and neutron and it was
our impression that the role was going
to be played by you well you know let me
ask you something
i saw i saw i saw clips from this movie
today i called my lawyers
i am liz show this this is clearly a
rip-off
this is clearly
i
i want in on i want in on the
merchandising i want a chunk of the
action yeah i mean you presumably have
copyright in your appearance
i don't think so no i don't think nbc
has that uh-huh yeah
it's worth a lot of money i can assure
you
well it was a disappointment martin
feels the same way i will come after you
i'll crush you all with my legal team
the little guy is good he's
uh he's smart he saves uh at least his
little part of the planet and it would
have been charming had you been doing it
because then you and i would have had
something in common you remember just
have a higher uh voice than the boy who
got the part so
i could have done it myself we'd have
both been saving the universe in one way
or another that is you and i we will
work together soon i assure you we'll do
a buddy comedy where we you know drive
around and go over a bridge and stuff
it'll be fun let me ask you about
a high honor which i also envy
madame tussauds made a wax figure of you
which they're displaying is it it's in
london is it also here in new york yeah
that's a miracle isn't it it can be in
two places at the same time the fact is
there's there's more than one but why do
you why do you end with sure do you
think everybody wants uh what do you
mean surely i have one yes sure cuckoo
what are you talking about
the world doesn't want to see a wax
replica of conan o'brien but you're here
you are you're an american institution
at least certainly a new york institute
i'm an american who's been
institutionalized yes
yeah thank you
i i want to uh
thanks for the pity um i
no but i i think that must be very
strange because these these wax figures
they don't look like wax figures i've
seen these things in person and they're
stunning what's it like to go and look
at
yourself in 3d quite seriously i found
it very very unnerving and of course at
the press release they wanted me to
stand nose to nose with my finger to
stand cheek by jowl and so forth but i
didn't want to look at him um
why not well actually if i had one i'd
be staring at it all day so pretty
maybe that's a good reason why you
shouldn't have one
touching it i don't think we should go
there at all yeah let's leave that alone
my weird fetish with my own wax figure
yeah
let me ask you about a christmas carol
please this is not you playing the role
with a lot of other people in a stage
production this is you providing
you provide the whole world of a
christmas carol you provide the
different voices you provide is this not
right this is this is just you alone
providing even the sound effects i tell
the story so i'm the narrator i i
physicalize all of the characters i
there's some disagreements how many but
there's somewhere between 35 and 40
characters and because i wanted it to be
purely an actor's evening we don't have
mechanical sound effects so i do the
sound effects violins doorbell chiming
clocks and so you're like geraldo
providing all this kind of exercise yeah
kerplash he's good we're all those very
good i could use some of that yeah what
so what kind of sounds are you doing are
you actually trying to mimic the sounds
well for instance in the fezziwig's
party there is a fiddler who plays for
the dancing and uh would you like a
little yeah
[Applause]
he is not a first class fiddle you are
yeah he's a little out of
[Music]
tune i just picture you
yeah the uh the the philharmonic have
not yet called but i'm expecting any
moment now i'd be cheap too i do i i if
i
like i do like a guy sawing wood and i
would probably i would probably work if
i was doing the role i would just work
in all these things that that that are
never in a christmas carol but suddenly
you know bob cratchit made a table
ladies and gentlemen
just just then colonel clink from
hogan's heroes showed up hugon
you know it'd just be
the whole thing would fall apart yeah do
you remember that thing that i said
about you being an institution yeah
i have to ask you um
about this you uh you apparently forgot
there you said there was something like
32 or 40 some odd characters that you do
you once forgot to include some of the
children and you had to improvise and
get them back you lost some kids that's
what you were doing i lost two i lost
two cratchits not once it was a few
nights ago and uh my wife was in the
audience that night and halfway through
the cratchit's
christmas lunch she said
i thought they had more children than
this there are two of them missing of
course i'm alone on the stage there's
nobody else there the fact is i omitted
to introduce them into the scene and
then all of a sudden there they were
talking they had come from nowhere so i
had to lean heavily on their voices and
their characterizations whenever they
came up that's what happens when you're
alone on stage the comforting thing is
that you can backtrack go forward it's a
little malleable you can play around
with it a little bit it's infinitely
malleable yes you are now shooting the
10th star trek movie at this moment and
i know there are a lot of people on the
web that want to know what's going on
anything you can share with us anything
people can look forward to how long do
we have oh there's a little enough time
i think to tell us give us give away
something that you're not supposed to
give away and get yourself in a lot of
trouble okay all right
um
uh i'm sitting in the captain's chair of
the enterprise all right
how's that
no just then you saw some wood yeah
then you play the box
one thing it doesn't have um it doesn't
have a a romantic storyline for the
captain this time i maybe they were
yeah thank you very much
you know it's still time to write in you
know yeah the the script can be fixed
and uh uh no romantic storyline but a
lot of high energy action i can tell you
i got to drive for two weeks our opening
two weeks of filming in the desert 200
miles or so from los angeles
a a futuristic 24th century off-road
vehicle built by the man who is
synonymous with off-road race a man
called ivan stewart built and designed
this
real live high-powered officer looks
like something that's from the future
right and i drove it everywhere for two
weeks it was a wonderful experience it's
like being in a very uh high-priced
nursery you know right
you know it's just a ford probe with
some fancy stuff on it
i assure you it's the real thing